this video is sponsored by you'll find
out on the 18th of February 2022 the UK
and Ireland were struck by storm Eunice
gusts of 196 kilometers per hour were
recorded on the Isle of Wight a record
for England a thousand people were
evacuated from the O2 Arena in London as
the roof was ripped open trees were
upended a church Spire was blown down in
Somerset 10 severe flood warnings were
issued the storm was an example of
explosive cyclogenesis intensifying out
of basically nothing on the 17th of
February yet it was identified as a
threat on the 14th and weather warnings
issued on the 16th thanks to incredibly
accurate meteorological forecasts only
three people in the UK and one in
Ireland lost their lives to the storm
modern meteorology is frankly a miracle
we are able to predict a vast powerful
storm like Eunice before it even forms
over the ocean and that saves life yet
one aspect of weather prediction remains
incredibly challenging precipitation
meaning Rain snow hail sleet but I'm
British so rain is perhaps the most
challenging part of the weather to
predict more than a few hours out in
order to understand why we have to look
at how the weather is predicted the
weather is how we refer to the state of
several variables in the air around us
temperature pressure humidity wind speed
these variables are all connected via
lots of equations some of them describe
how these variables are related to one
another at a given location like how air
pressure temperature and density are all
related in the ideal gas equation While
others describe how changes in these
variables over an area relate to other
variables for example how wind speed is
related to the gradient in pressure in
the surrounding area we can take the
current state of the atmosphere the
values of pressure and temperature and
so on and using these equations predict
what is going to happen at some some
time in the near future it has to be the
near future by the way because uh if you
don't do that this approach goes very
wrong very quickly doing so creates a
future state of the atmosphere maybe an
hour into the future that you can then
apply your atmospheric equations to
again to go another hour into the future
and you could do that again and again
and eventually predict the weather of 24
hours into the future and Beyond but to
do that by hand producing a weather
forecast with pencil and paper would
take months historical side note someone
called Lewis fry Richardson tried to do
this in 1922. if you want to learn more
about that you can read about it in my
book firmament an introduction to a
history of atmospheric science named as
a waterstones book of the year and is
now available as a paperback in the UK
and Commonwealth and Europe I think
looks all floppy link is down there in
the description sorry Americans you get
the paperback next year I think but the
hardback is now available for you anyway
back to predicting the weather to save
us lots of time we represent those
equations describing the atmosphere in a
way that a computer can understand and
do for us that means instead of
describing the atmosphere over the UK
for example like this smoothly varying
we describe it like this we've broken it
down into chunks or to use the fancy
term discretized it we measure the value
of atmospheric variables on this grid
and then apply the equations only at
locations on this grid we can then
iterate into the future like I've
mentioned before of course the more
locations you do this for the higher
your resolution the more accurate your
approximation of the real atmosphere
becomes in Practical terms you add as
many points as your computer can
tolerate without bursting into flames
doing the calculation most Regional
weather prediction models have points
that are a few kilometers apart but why
is that a problem for rainfall
specifically physical processes that
lead to rainfall they happen well below
the resolution of the typical weather
forecast computer models that we have so
these processes are things like a water
vapor condensing around little
impurities within clouds also convective
updrafts and downdrafts lead to intense
rainfall all of these are happening well
below the resolution of the models which
is typically one kilometer for local
models and maybe 10 kilometers from
Global models the end user really needs
to know on quite a local scale whether
or not it's going to rain but also
ideally how much it's going to rain and
precipitation varies quite sharply over
small scales and as a result these
processes that lead to rainfall they are
what we call parameterized and that
really means that they're very crudely
approximated within the models and
therefore the resulting predicted
rainfall can be really quite inaccurate
this is Dr Andrew McRae and he's joined
by Dr Lucy Harris two of the authors of
this paper that was published late last
year that improves the forecasting of
rainfall over the UK using machine
learning techniques so we use a machine
learning technique called a generative
adversarial Network to achieve our
downscaling this may sound complicated
but the idea is actually very similar to
a tool that you may have used websites
like image.upscaler allow you to input
low resolution images and through
machine learning techniques receive
higher resolution images these tools are
up sampling or improving the resolution
of the image similarly the generative
adversarial Network or gan from the
paper takes in the low resolution output
from a global weather prediction model
over the UK information such as pressure
temperature and humidity on the low
resolution grid but also some extra
information like a high resolution map
of the height of the landscape of the UK
and then does its fancy maths magic it's
really
and outputs a higher resolution weather
forecast for the UK so it's very similar
to the idea of things like image up
sampling that's used in in computer
Graphics one thing that's quite
different than the work that we've done
is that our model takes into account
basically that the weather forecast can
be wrong so our model we take in a
single weather forecast we train it
against a separate data set a
radar-based data set of what actually
happened and of course there's going to
be differences so it's not just that one
of them is high resolution than the
other but it's also that the weather
forecast said the rain will be here and
actually it was here but that's not all
there's a fundamental difference between
an image upscaler and this paper and
it's to do with the nature of the
atmosphere the atmosphere has a very
sensitive dependence to initial
conditions and so if your model has
taken the cloud to slightly the wrong
place then even without all of this
issue with the parameterizations the
rainfall is still going to fall in the
wrong place any uncertainty in how you
initialize a forecast such as not being
exactly sure what temperatures are at
all your grid locations something that
by the way is inevitable and the error
in your forecast will grow exponentially
over time that's that's chaos theory one
way to tackle that is to use stochastic
models where you have a slight amount of
noise added to your input sort of just
random noise and you see how much of an
effect that has in the output so if
we're slightly wrong about the initial
conditions
do we come to the same conclusion or are
we wildly diverging away so the
stochastic model tries to give a
probabilistic representation of the set
of possible outputs given a slight
uncertainty around the initial
conditions and this is how weather
forecasting is done you don't just get
one forecast out of your model you
generate an ensemble of outcomes given
slightly different inputs which can tell
you the most likely forecast but also
tell you how certain you can be about
that forecast the tool that Lucy and
Andrew and others have put together is
an extension of that idea married with
machine learning techniques and provides
post-processing to rainfall forecasts
specifically I'd say that our model does
three main things really so number one
it can correct biases if you produce the
large number of Ensemble forecasts and
took the average then that would be
different to the input so that's
correcting the bias number two it adds
variability and number three increases
the resolution so somehow our generative
adversarial Network approach is doing
all three of those things at once so
considering how effective this tool is
and the paper is clear it is effective
you may well ask why don't we use more
machine learning in weather and climate
prediction in fact why even bother
creating really complicated weather
forecasting models and just let machine
learning do the whole thing
well there have been some very exciting
papers that have come out in the past
couple of years literally within the
past few months there's been a couple
more huge papers that have dropped one
by Huawei uh with a model called pangu
weather and if just before Christmas uh
there was one by deepmind I've forgotten
what they call their model but it's
called grafcast the paper by deepmind
these are purely machine learning based
models and these last two papers
particularly so pennyweather by Huawei
and the deepmind paper they've shown
that their machine learning model is
basically On a par with the best
existing weather models maybe better I
think the rate of progress is just so
vast that I would not be surprised
anymore if a few years from now
um the machine learning models
outperform the existing models by far so
now at least post processing using
machine learning techniques such as
described by this paper is a valuable
tool in weather prediction and going
forwards May provide a crucial tool in
predicting extreme rainfall events and
thus disaster relief as well as you know
reminding you to pack a raincoat no no
no no no no now I am delighted to
announce that I have reached a milestone
in my YouTube career I want you all to
join in with this one bring up the
karaoke lyrics because
this video was sponsored by nordvpn we
did it everyone we did it give me a high
five
but what is a nordvpn I hear you ask a
VPN is a way of obscuring your IP
address making it appear as if you're
browsing the internet from another
location that you can choose that has
privacy benefits but it also allows you
to access location-specific services for
example in the UK and want to watch TV
that's only available on American
streaming services get not a VPN set
your location to be in America want to
save money up to 85 on renting a car get
nordvpn set your location to be in the
cheapest country for the service I've
personally used nordvpn for several
years now mostly to access location
specific stuff and I can categorically
say that several videos on this YouTube
channel would not exist if I didn't have
access to nordvpn's Features it's just a
really genuinely useful tool but as well
as being useful it's easy to use the
fastest VPN out there and you can cover
cover six devices on the same plan and
all that costs just a few quid a month
this isn't an exaggeration this isn't a
bit I am genuinely delighted to be
working with nordvpn on this sponsorship
it's like another gemstone in my
YouTuber Infinity Gauntlet I think it's
a great service I use it I think you'll
like it too if you would like to get
yourself an essential tool for browsing
online and help out the Channel please
head to nordvpn.com Simon Clark to get
the two-year plan and an additional
month for free that's nordvpn.com Simon
Clark with thanks to nordvpn for
sponsoring one of my videos
thank you so much for watching and thank
you also to Andrew and Lucy for giving
up their time to talk about their paper
if you found the discussion in this
video interesting and in particular
stuff to do with machine learning in the
future of weather prediction then on my
patreon there is a bonus video with an
Extended Cut of the interviews that I
did where we talk about that role of
machine learning and weather and climate
in much more detail the name scrolling
below me right now are my executive
producers over on patreon.com forward
slash Simon oxfiz if you would like to
help me make bigger and better videos
then please do consider supporting there
you get access to bonus content and a
monthly behind the scenes Vlog and if
you support the top tier you get your
name in the video credits please do pop
the video a like if you enjoyed it and
please do share it with people who you
think may be interested in this topic if
you'd like to see some more videos from
me then there's some recommended viewing
on the screen here and that just leads
me to say thank you again for watching
I'll see you in the next one